kiev la situation est pour l'instant
relativement plus calme même si les
soldats se rapprochent de la capitale
ils font face en tout cas la résistance
tenace des ukrainiens la situation reste
tendue également dans la ville de vassil
qui vivent à une quarantaine de
kilomètres au sud de kiev une ville qui
a été bombardé par l'armée russe où l'on
retrouve tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial cyril payen que se passe-t-il
autour de vous
écouter judith voilà les effets concrets
de de l'aviation militaire de la russie
par l'ukraine où son nous sommes comme
vous le disiez dans une ville garnison
vassil qui va 40 km au sud de la
capitale ukrainienne est ce que vous
voyez certainement à l'image de 2,2 de
georges-besse c'est une école qui a été
frappé par les par un missile russe une
totale destruction de cet édifice
d'ailleurs il ya encore à mes pieds bien
des cahiers d'écoliers des éléments d
des manteaux donc on peut imaginer que
le bilan a été de quelques dizaines de
morts ici même c'est une ville qui a été
frappée dès le début de l'offensive
puisque c'est une ville garnison et
qu'il y a également un aéroport
militaire dont le dessin était pour les
l'offensive rue de prendre et aéroports
ainsi pour pouvoir est bien lancé des
assauts depuis cet aéroport c'était il
ya eu une riposte des forces du
chrétienne mais beaucoup de morts et on
sait que le mode le mode opératoire qui
a eu lieu ici c'était une équipe de
saboteurs russes qui étaient infiltrés
c'est un mode opératoire qui s'est
beaucoup répondu 1 depuis le début de
l'offensive dans les villes ukrainiennes
et qui a attaqué de l'intérieur c'est
pour ça qu'il ya eu 7 ce missile dont
vous pouvez voir l'impact du missile qui
a frappé on peut ça donne une idée de la
violence de l'impact alors aujourd'hui
cette ville est un front puisque
évidemment kef et est encerclé presque
entièrement à part la ce sud et le nord
ouest nous savons qu'à quelques
kilomètres de là où on se trouve il y à
ce front où les forces du crânienne sont
dit on est un peu débordé donc on sent
que ce rouleau compresseur militaire
russe est en train d'entrer en action
c'est un véritable rouleau compresseur
qui est en train de rentrer en action le
nous sommes là depuis quelques instants
il y avait déjà eu plusieurs sirènes des
sirènes d'alert pour les bombardements
aériens et les habitants de cette
commune et pour ceux qui sont restés
parce que je peux vous dire qu'il ya eu
aussi un exode massif
et on le comprend parfaitement quand on
voit le degré de destruction de
l'endroit où nous sommes en plein dedans
plein en pleine rue en plein centre de
delà de cette ville de garnison à 40
kilomètres de kiev pour ceux qui sont
restés bien toute la nuit nous ont-ils
dit ils sont restés dans des abris dans
des souterrains dans des caves puisque
lee a eu toute la nuit des alertes aux
bombardements et on entendu une
explosion peut-être mais donc c'est une
situation évidemment précaire et qui
reflète totalement ce qui se passe ici
dans la glaise dans les villes
satellitaire de l'oblast de l'oblast de
kiev qui est cette grande région
administrative qui couvre plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres carrés autour de
kiev le moral des ukrainiens il est
toujours un combatif
oui c'est ça qui est assez incroyable et
saisissant cette âme à mesure que l'on
vit maintenant ici avec les ukrainien à
kiev il y à des barricades des barrages
qui sont fabriqués tenus par des forces
de défense territoriale qui sont en fait
des habitants des quartiers qui ont
décidé de prendre les armes eux-mêmes et
de défendre coûte que coûte cette ville
cette ville qui est de plus en plus
attaquée on peut rapporter par exemple
comme nous étions à kiev ce matin des
bombardements incessants que l'on entend
des explosions depuis le début de la
nuit et qui continue encore ça c'est au
nord à 40 kilomètres de kiev dans la
ville de dire pink et fera durement
touchés on sait qu'un un pont a été
détruit sa beauté par les forces
ukrainienne pour freiner l'avancée des
forces russes il y as on déplore il n'y
a pas de bilan pour l'instant mais
plusieurs civils qui auraient été tuées
dans des échauffourées
donc les combats font rage haïr pin
puisque c'était souhaite c'est eux et
tout en vain de se resserrer après avoir
pris l'est le or eh bien aujourd'hui
c'est le nord-ouest avec la ville d'hier
pin sur laquelle les faits les forces
russes font énormément pression ce qui
veut laisser laissé entendre que d'ici
quelques jours et bien il n'y aura plus
que l'accès sud là où nous nous trouvons
qui skie la sorte de la seule porte
d'entrée et de sortie à la capitale de
la capitale ukrainienne kiev mais tout
le monde ici même si tout le monde est
prêt à défendre la ville tout le monde
s'attend à ce que le siège des buts un
jour ou l'autre c'est une question de
jours peut-être deux semaines mais
chacun se prépare un long siège de kiev
ici merci beaucoup cyril payen et merci
pour les images ailleurs georges ya ce
but